cinquantaine de pompiers à l'oeuvre une
quarantaine de policiers et gendarmes
mobilisés
la place entièrement bouclé et l'unique
supermarché de ce quartier de sens en
flammes
triste spectacle pour des habitants
médusés consterné et a battu vous n'avez
vraiment vraiment pas besoin de ça et je
suis triste mais profondément pour les
habitants de quartiers et c'est pour eux
et pour les personnes âgées qui se
déplace dans ce sens commercial pour
faire les courses
ces gens là ils vont aller où maintenant
vers 13 heures samedi
un violent incendie se déclare à
l'intérieur de ce supermarché situé au
coeur du quartier des champs plaisants
le magasin est alors vide et aucune
victime ne sera à déplorer
la poste est un magasin de textile
voisins ont été également de toucher un
important dispositif de secours et de
sécurité a dû être déployés selon la
justice
un véhicule est entré par la réserve et
le feu se serait déclaré dans la foulée
pour le maire de la ville très vite
arrivés sur les lieux
la piste criminelle ne fait guère de
doute à moins de penser qu'un camion on
peut se déplacer tout seul rentrée
mettre le feu dans un oui oui oui je
pense que c'est criminel heures
maintenant quelle nature je n'en sais
rien
voilà et je le regrette vraiment
infiniment d'autant plus que je répète
les habitants ne mérite pas ça une
enquête pour destruction par incendie a
été ouverte mais aucune piste n'est
privilégiée
un dispositif de surveillance a été
maintenue sur place toute la nuit avec
cet incendie les habitants donc perdu
leur unique supermarché et le marché qui
se tient sur la place le dimanche matin
a été annulé